oh what kind of things didn't you
understand about men
um because this is a very the red pill
Community as you probably figured out
we're it's very unforgiving
um they don't like it when women come
into the space they really don't so
what's that so so so what have you
learned about men from the outside
looking in rather from the inside if
that makes sense I'll give you an
example I I feel like in and I've been
in a relation
where like I I was hurt by someone okay
and so I kind of looked for problems
with the next person oh okay and I just
realized like I was like a headache to
him because like I was looking for
problems and like and I would say like
you know if a guy is gonna gonna cheat
or gonna do something like that like you
kind of just has to let them do what
he's gonna do okay and I I don't condone
cheating um I don't I don't like it sure
but it's like what what it what good is
it gonna do for you to like look like
it's kind of like it's not feminine to
like look for problems it's kind of like
if it comes to you that's one thing sure
I think that's like I don't want to say
like let him cheat but and I feel like
men are more likely to be faithful to
you if you just like if you leave us
yeah yeah alone and men men don't want
to talk to us either that's the other
thing I learned that is that is listen
that was going to be my next question
the transition I'm gonna read the super
chat then we'll get into that uh age of
machines five dollar our Super Chat he
said that disembodied comment is real uh
with women mom included I have to check
them and ask them uh ask them what did I
say or how does that apply to me yeah
again hey would you would you ever cook
for a man hell no would you cook for
Denzel Washington well yes of course she
would yeah that just proves that that
you're not thinking and listen to be
fair to the women
when you ask would you do XYZ for a man
you're not you're there's no
qualifications you're just telling a man
just average Rank and file man
approaching talking when you say that
men don't want to talk to you anymore
what does that mean oh like men
it's like when they get home they just
want to relax oh yes like we want to
tell you about our day
and and I remember like I've been in a
relationship where like I came I came
back like and he was like could you just
could you just please just and and I
don't even be like that was so rude but
like it's kind of like us women a lot of
times we take things personal sure and I
think we're a partially narcissistic and
like we really can't just women in jail
we think everything's about us yes yes
you do when sometimes it's like that's
just how guys are they don't want to
talk to you they don't want to hear
about it it's not personal we just need
a little bit of space yeah yeah and I
was like oh so you gotta I'll just be
sitting in my room like go talk to your
girlfriends like wow that is what you
are the the the things that you uh the
things that you say okay oh this is my
oh that's my recruiter actually okay the
things that oh perfect perfect by the
way uh by the way uh we are going to
have a menstrual cycle coach on the
hashtag how to relationship podcast say
what on Saturday yeah I listen
I'm open-minded
um but but to hear you say hey this is
how we are we're a little bit
narcissistic we are we think
everything's about us the the
transparency even sitting there the
transparents I was Pearl just learned
about the extent of my criminal record I
told her the whole story but even you
admitted hey like we like we love us the
bad boys we like guys with criminal like
and women don't openly talk about that
like you do yeah because I don't think
we consciously like no no of course not
like we don't think about it no so we
don't and like even when I was saying
like oh we kind of like the guys that
cheat yeah like if we didn't like
cheaters why are we all getting cheated
on there you go there it is and I used
to not like and I don't agree with him
but it's kind of like and I think we all
want a guy that could cheat and would be
faithful there you go that's the ideal
yes uh but it's like we all start like
how do relationships start nowadays a
situation
you're a side chick trying to get
promoted to the phone oh my God yeah
like modern women are side chicks
because like what are you in a situation
chip what is that you're side chick well
I'm in a situationship and they say it
with pride yeah the guy I'm in a
situationship has a yacht yeah but he
also has a wife and another side chick
so where does that leave you you know
it's ridiculous
say why and
very good
so I don't don't do that don't do that
lady what but what you just said is like
like a guy like that's a place you know
no of course but what you just said is
that proposed a little while ago women
and I say this oh I've been saying this
for years women neverly consciously
think about what's going on in the
firmware so when they actually hear it
out loud for the first time their their
their initial reaction is to is to
disagree right yeah yeah you like you
know would you take your boyfriend back
if he cheated well a 12 out of 10 girls
are gonna say no but then you ask them
have you ever taken back a cheating
boyfriend then they're kind of like well
okay you know it's funny a lot of times
when he stops cheating like you know
it's funny and what I realized and I I I
did this too I can't even like it's like
when they cheat you'll take them back
but you're mentally getting ready to
leave yep and so that's what they'll do
and like even if he doesn't cheat for a
couple more months you're You're gone
you know what I'm saying so it's like
well it depends on the guy's value too
yeah true but it depends on his value
yeah but it's interesting because a lot
of times when I ask like girls like when
he's not cheating that's when they leave
there we go these guys we don't even
[ __ ] know but listen listen you were
all right you're 100 right if you
cheated on me blah blah blah blah they
take him back all of a sudden now he's
checking in he's being open he's being
honest et cetera et cetera now they
leave because he's just not the same
person no no he's boring dude and this
is I've asked this question on the fresh
and fit podcast before I asked these
girls would uh uh would you rather be
with a man who cheats or a man who is
boring and it was [ __ ] crickets
because they'd never been forced to
think about it from that perspective
that's that that's that that's that
verbal uh verbal non uh non-confirmation
where they're like wait a minute I've
never really thought of it that way
because would you want a boring man uh
no uh would you wanna would you want a
guy who cheats no okay if either or
because a lot of times it is either or
if a guy is boring probably couldn't
cheat if a guy if a guy could cheat he's
probably not boring yeah yeah female
nature I'll tell you what oh is one of
our cats going crazy oh okay
um uh if men approaching women
um there are there are articles coming
out all the time about guys that are
checking out of the dating Market guys
that are saying you know what they're
throwing up their hands or like you know
what I can't do this anymore I'm not
messing with American women what are
your thoughts on Western guys Western
men uh checking out of the dating Market
what are your thoughts on that I mean I
understand stand it and I it was
interesting when I first started in red
pill I didn't because I'm very much Pro
like family and marriage and I was like
why wouldn't men want to get married but
oh my God yeah but it's like yeah but
it's like okay the the product like
let's just say women like you guys are
the buyers for the products are worse
than ever before we're less pure yep
we're older yep
um we're less loyal and we're paid to
leave yes we're literally paid like you
could be a single mother and you're paid
to do it you're paid to get divorced
like so it's like even like I think men
and women are bullshitty as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible